foreign
[Music]
s ready
all set
okay quiet everybody everybody uh we
don't have to repeat it but yes you're
right we have to emphasize thank you to
everyone here that he mentioned film
independent the Royal Centerburg theater
everyone who hopped on board behind the
scenes as well as in terms of the
lighting and sound and I want to also
thank
all of the interpreters you'll be seeing
on stage
and I also want to thank
each and every cast member all right
camera
action whom you'll see and who will hear
reading Sunset Boulevard and signing
Sunset Boulevard with me I had an
original story kicking around Paramount
my agent told me it was dead as a
doornail but I knew a big shot over
there who'd always liked me and
the time had come to take a little
advantage of it
there are a great cast I might be biased
but I'm telling you they're great
they're incredible they're marvelous
I just want to tell you all how happy I
am
in the studio making a picture again
I just I was offered to do this it was
my first directorial job and I thought
well why not give it a try
it wouldn't hurt but what an experience
it's been and I want to thank them for
that opportunity
you've got the best man for it right
here on this lot Alan Ladd good change
of pace for Alan Ladd there's another
thing it's pretty simple to shoot a lot
of outdoor stuff that you can make a
whole thing for under a million
what you're going to be seeing this
afternoon is different than anything
you've probably ever seen before if
you've been a regular here at the
Wallace you'll see both deaf and hearing
actors actors working together but what
you will see is American Sign Language
and you'll hear spoken English and we've
paired one actor with another deaf and
hearing
and I promise you I will never desert
you again because after Salome we'll
make another Beach and another and
another and
you might have been familiar with that
for us theater you've seen actors
working together but it's never been
like this where we've done a live
reading and this is a wonderful
experiment I trust that you'll enjoy
this experiment in theater and right
along with us thank you so very much for
coming today on this Saturday afternoon
enjoy the show all right Mr DeMille I'm
ready
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign